there's a Halloween episode for two and
a Half Men which is gonna start off the
season and you you dress in this this
has got to be kind of cool for you you
oh yeah revive one of your great roles
ducky in pretty and pink and you you
play ducky and Ashton
I think Kutcher plays the elf azam be
Elvis zombie Elvis yes I think we have a
picture here you there you are I was
shocked I looked at this and I thought
you look exactly
you're the guck man again it's amazing
you just you you can go right back to
that I well I was really worried well
first of all that there was the help of
a wig there which is very helpful but
you're worried because it's kind of sad
when you see a famous teenage character
and you realize oh wait they grew up and
aren't a teenager anymore you know it's
like it's like it was like fat Elvis
remember fat Elvis because he was still
wearing the outfit
yeah thin Elvis but he was nothing
anymore right right and that's what I
was worried about but thankfully I can
still get away with it as you as you saw
it it worked it worked pretty well it
worked where the nice was it nice was it
was a little nostalgic for you to put
back the the costume back on again it
was a little bit the nicest thing was I
had to go from the costume trailer to
the to my trailer and when a Warner
Brothers tourist went by and they went
insane hey and that was really great
it's night that when the tour goes by
that's a nice feeling yes you get like a
little sometimes they'll be a little bit
down about something I'm walking along
and this is this this tram will go by
and they be like
and I pick right up but every now and
then one comes by and I'm like hi
absolutely nothing yes I have that too
and then I'm like what's with them and
I'll follow it later on I'll find out
like oh they're from Tokyo you know
foreign yeah that's that's what it is
where they're from Little Tokyo a little
pen they just don't care just don't care
you